there are caped crusaders
galactic Guardians
and amazing web-slinger's for over a
decade only one hero dared to be wimpy
he is the Wimpy Kid there's one thing
I've learned from my years of begging
kid that you have zero control over your
own life
it was excited about the great Heffley
road trip four days in the car together
this summer
Claire Expos in Indianapolis this
weekend is only she winches away
tomorrow we ride compadre he's going
further changing destination than he's
ever gone before and becoming a rebel I
need to file a missing persons report to
me what do your parents think about you
guys coming to the expo to play video
game oh they have no idea frankly Gil
they're a little slow actually
I'd like to report a double murder from
20th century five
a wimp will rise well you said you want
to get the boat on the water the summer
the long-haul
leads the new owners the hunt we love
sucks murder all this started once leads
took over I thought we were lifeguards
everything that you guys are talking
about sounds like a really